هذا وقد طالب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني وزراء
الدفاع الاوروبيين المجتمعين في السويد
طالبهم بدعم بلاده عسكريا بانظمه دفاع جوي
وبمليون قطعه من الذخيره لدعمها في حربها
ضد روسيا وقد بحث وزراء الدفاع الاوروبيون
في اجتماعهم بالعاصمه السويديه
الدعم الغربيه لاوكرانيا من اجل مواجهه ما
قد يحصل بعد بخموت
من جهته قلب مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال في ختام
اجتماع وزراء الدفاع الاوروبيين في
ستوكهولم ان هناك توافقا على معظم اجراءات
دعم اوكرانيا لكنه اشار الى ان هناك اسئله
لا تزال معلقه واضاف المسؤول الاوروبي ان
هناك حاجه لحزمه دعم جديده لايصال قذائف
من عيار 155 ملم لاوكرانيا وتوقع تدريب
ثلاثين الف جنديا اوكرانيا بحلول نهايه
هذا العام